what guys how are you guys all doing him
because they're having a wonderful day
and I know you came for a merging video
but real quick before we get into the
merges I just want to start by saying
that the channels kind of been getting a
lot of you lately that I don't know if I
necessarily expected so if you guys have
any way of improving my videos feel free
to leave them and comment down below I
want to start editing these merchants a
lot more however I kind of want to just
get them out for the people that are
currently new in my channel so the
videos be slowly and surely getting
better though if you guys have any ways
of improving feel freely constructive
criticism down below and with that being
said let's get into the merchants ago so
I went to work and bought some gilded
boots so hopefully we will be able to
get some margins on those so
surprisingly it didn't take that long to
get my gilded boots to sell I sold them
for the price that I talked about
earlier so we're going to take that out
and now we are over the 13 mil mark
13.15 and we'll find a different item
now so there we go we had 200 torsional
seeds to buy so we're gonna list them up
for 41 0400 hello later some of the
torsional seeds have sold however they
kind of has stopped selling so I'm going
to assume someone under cubby I'm just
gonna throw them in 441 k and probably
leave them overnight I would imagine
it's about damn time so I want to bed
and finally all these torso seats if so
I believe that the cash neck is about
where it should be it's at 13.5 I'm
gonna have to go back in the footage and
check every now and then I throw cash
over two of my new account and sometimes
I forget some over there anyways
nonetheless let's find out all right
well one of my little nap blowpipes one
of my heavy ballistas bought i was
merging it on my main so i decided i
would take it on over here as well so as
you can see i can sell it on for that i
was buying some other ones however I
kept one on this account to actually use
with my own money huh however as you can
see i'll be making 140 k profit off of
this if it does sell well checked out
the OS buddy guy price and the price of
selling him for my other account for
some reason they weren't even selling at
this price for a while so I decided to
list them up for this and it ended up
selling so i am going to actually
and try to merge more of these
about to go over to my dad's for
Father's Day however gonna do this merch
why I'm there just because tourists will
seeds are about 1k below what they
usually are at and they have a pretty
decent margin on them right now so I'm
just going to throw them back in for
let's just say 40k n800 GP and hopefully
those will sell so if they do it's 5.8
no I thought them for that so that's 170
k profit which would be really nice
alright so got back from my dad's and so
as you can see almost all the tourists
will see it's a ball I'm pretty sure I
hit my limit so we're gonna have to
check out what the price is now however
the other ones did indeed sell so we're
going to collect all of this and then
we're going to see if we can buy it or
steal hopefully alright so we've hit our
limit so I'm gonna go home and I made it
count by one real quick all right there
you go so as you can see it is buying
441 pretty much 500 so that means we can
sell all of these on 441 500 obviously
and there we go so we're going to be
able to sell that for eight point three
mil which is actually insane give me one
second so what that means is eight point
three mil thus which means we're about
to make 600 k or so off of the this
merch I do believe let me check it and
we're about to make 600 k off of this
merge that didn't say
so I saw there were pretty good margins
on these tyrannical rings actually
really good is it if you think about it
but I'm going to go and sell these on I
believe the price is around five point
nine mil took barely time at all but all
of the torso seats have butts we're
going to list them up for HH at least 39
5 I would imagine so I'm probably gonna
go about 40k with it and hopefully that
sells probably go 4,400 so maybe I made
a mistake with the tyrannical rings but
we'll let him sell the torso seats
however has sold so I'm gonna find
another item so both of my tyrannical
rings have bought so we should be able
to make some money off of these again
I'm actually probably just going to
merge them again since they actually
didn't take that long and make quick
300k on so I was doing heavy ballistas
on my main and they're decent margins so
I'm just gonna list this back up the
problem is is I don't have enough money
to constantly like buy and sell them
which is kind of annoying however I will
be trying to do as many as I can of them
not even a couple minutes later my heavy
ballista salt so i'll be able buy
another one
Oh
we wait to change and then solve
just got back from work and as you can
see i bought and sold a ballista and
there are 150 k margins on it which is
you know really good however i just
don't know if these margins are gonna be
able to stay and I'm kind of nervous
that they won't it didn't take too long
probably about five minutes or so but I
have people us to has sold so we're just
gonna I don't know probably stand this
for a little while at this point out
it's a easy easy just true probably a
minute later not even any like oh my
gosh the profit is going to just roll in
on these another one but that's real
tough real these are insane profit hey
there we go got another one to some um
just gonna keep doing it just keep doing
our thing gotta be hit my limit soon I'd
imagine but nonetheless here's another
other one bought and sold however once
this is done I actually think I just
found a pretty good merch of my main I
sold the hosta into the GE and in doing
so I found out that it was selling about
180 k below the like price that OS buddy
has a net which means i'd be able to
sell it pretty quickly for the price
house but he has that so hopefully we
can make some money off this real quick
and then hop on over to that as soon as
i was ending that last clip this bought
this and this is what i'm saying these
mergers are insane i don't i don't get
it i'm making 150k off at each one of
these oh my god not even a minute later
man this is i just i don't know how to
explain this it's just non-stop cash
going in right now i wish i had cash
ready to go on my main right now right
now if you look on my main i'm currently
selling these which is actually pretty
sick it's gonna be like a 800 k profit
if they sell however I want to just
constantly be merging these blisters
right now so now we've hit our limit so
we are complete with that we are
actually almost at 16 mil I believe ya
15.5 or 15.95 gonna go into the houses
now and hopefully those will have good
Marge alright so it is morning as you
guys can see I have a ton of you seeds
18 of them did not buy however I have
180 so basically we're going to see what
the sapling price is real quick and then
that'll determine what we're able to do
with these so as you can see 87.3 k I
bought them for 80.3 so that means i'm
making 7k off of each one of these you
seeds which means i'm literally about to
make like 1.3 mil it's just insane holy
what seemed like years later all of
these you saplings have sold however you
know how I said I was gonna sell them
for like 87 k and they end up dropping
mostly because people just kept
undercutting each other nonetheless we
are up to 16.7 ml which is a lot of
progress I think this is where I'm going
to end the video so I hope you guys did
enjoy this video there's a decent amount
of progress and I can't wait to flip
some more nonetheless hope you guys
enjoyed if you guys did feel free to
drop a like if there's any way i can
improve this and you guys have ideas for
that feel free that is comment down
below and if you want to see future
episodes feel free to subscribe done the
less hope you guys have a wonderful day
and peace